[Musique]
bonsoir
alors j'ai bien écouté mes petits
camarades ce soir et demain je suis
d'accord avec la mixité c'est bien non
remplies si je dis pas de bêtises c'est
déjà en place non c'est je crois que sur
l'égalité des salaires ça a été fait bon
je ne suis clairement pas le caution le
la caution intellectuelle de cette
soirée
moi je suis la génération beverly et
lissant y en ad'autres ce soir alors
est-ce que parmi les filles présentes ce
soir il y en a qui comme moi étaient
amoureuses de dylan
ah bah oui vous aussi monsieur mixité ce
soir alors j'aimerais quand même vous
remettre dans le truc
wilane c'était un torturé alcoolique
ah mais c'est normal parce qu'en général
il faut beaucoup de connard pour arriver
au gentil c'est normal alors en fait moi
je suis experte de la loose de l'amour
ah ah pardon il ya peut-être des
personnes qui me connaissent pas la luz
en fait c'est quand on est seul
et qu'on a faim très faim
je trouve qu'on a un mouvement est
plutôt égaux enfin je jure par exemple
un homme qui enchaîne les conquêtes
on va dire de lui que c'est un playboy
en séducteur un tueur ya plein d'options
possibles ans et une femme qui enchaîne
les conquêtes
on va dire que c'est une alors ya aussi
plusieurs autres options possibles
il ya en effet [ __ ] [ __ ] fille
facile plein d'options égalité
[Musique]
ah oui je voudrais donner un petit
message aux personnes en couple présent
de ce soir ne jugez pas trop vite la
lose la roue tourne
elle a tourné pour moi parce que je suis
passé de la luz de l'amour à la luz de
la santé oui j'ai eu un cancer du sein
pour mes 30 ans c'est mon petit côté
angelina jolie alors tout va bien je
suis là et et mousse
ils sont là a nommé jérôme on sait à mes
14 ans je ne serai jamais pamela
anderson
en même temps je suis j lo duca
oui je sais ça surprend toujours cette
prééminence je t'avais pas en fait on se
dit de faire ça va et je me retourne ça
bug
vous savez en fait aux états unis sont
kim kardashian à kim n'est pas sur le
grand écran
en voilà et en france il y à moi je
tiens tout de même à préciser qu'elle a
payé des millions de dollars pour la
voir moi c'est cadeau
[Musique]
ouais c'est mon héritage merci papa
merci maman
ils sont dans la salle face à la maladie
on est égaux hommes et femmes en fait le
médecin qui vous soit il va falloir un
homme ou une femme en vous il va avoir
un être humain avec un problème qui doit
tout simplement de façon pragmatique
réglé ah ben on n'est pas rien ah ben
c'est ok d'accord et donc je suis un
bonhomme en russie ben non on regarde on
n'est pas pareil attend ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'à 3 on se met torse nu ok
1 2 3 et on a appris hier les gars on
n'est pas pareil un jour je me suis
retrouvé avec deux hommes au dessus de
mes seins oui je sais j'aurais dû être
contente
et en fait ils s'apprêtaient à foncine
sombre
j'ai dit une sonde dans mon sein sans
anesthésie
j'ai fait pousse à j'avais demandé une
anesthésie oh ouais mais franchement
enfin l'anesthésié ça va être une piqûre
de plus franchement le truc c'est pas
douloureux et c'est rapide mais c'est
pas douloureux hockey a alors payé pour
que ce soit plus clair pour vous en
faites ce que je vais faire si je vais
prendre ma sont pas
et je vais l'enfance et dans ta big
quand je devais me rendre là mes séances
de rayons de radiothérapie en fait je
devais traverser torse nu en couloir
passant de l'hôpital
je m'étais permis dire que question
intimité on avait vu mieux et donc on
m'avait dit mais franchement parler à
des gens qui passent mais c'est pas
grand chose
ok est-ce que l'ars veut tous passés
dans l'allée voilà il ya deux années
c'est super vous passez tous torses nus
ya aucun souci et presque personne
deux mille personnes allez-y foncez à
ceci dit je suis en train de me dire
peut-être qu'il y avait les mecs ça vous
excite de voir une fille passait comme
ça torse nu par applause quel mec serait
excité de voir une fille comme ça au la
mauvaise foi
une fois j'ai dû passer une irm
ah oui alors pour les anglophones ces
rôles on est bien je sais pas si vous
avez déjà passé une irm pour vous
expliquer si c'est pas le cas en fait
vous êtes plus enfin j'avais le droit de
garder ma culotte princesse tam tam
on se refait pas quand même mes
chaussettes et en fait vous avez une
blouse qui est ouverte sur la poterie
vous avez les salaires et un petit
cathéter est en fait c'est vraiment le
meilleur moment pour entendre un truc
que les médecins adore dire détendue bah
oui c'est vrai écoute en fait j'ai
actuellement du sang qui dépasse de mon
cathéter tu as de la chance d'habitude
je fais un malaise à la vue du sang
j'attends de savoir si ma tumeur est
bien parti à droite et s'il y en a pas
une autre à bouche
alors oui oui oui oui je dis comme un
cri manque de la détente
je suis détendu mais ça je passais à la
fin l'examen je me suis relevé et du
coup en fait j'avais toujours là la
blouse ouverte sur ma poitrine nue et
donc il ya je vois qu'il ya un monsieur
en costume qui qui passe la tête
donc je me suis permis de demander à la
radiologue qui s'était mais seulement
sur rien sans remettre ça je suis désolé
j'étais pas au courant qu'ils étaient
les journées portes ouvertes ya une
femme avec les s'ennuyait rennes bloc 3
venez les gars bah oui comme ça avec un
peu de chance
tous les internes au robinet sans d'ici
la fin de la journée j'ai rencontré un
radiologue pendant 1 à radio thérapie
mon fils qui est que j'avais des nausées
suite aux séances de rayons et alors
quand je lui ai dit ça on a fait un
dessin à la tôle ou de landes il vous
connaissez vous attendez pas autant de
cultures j'ai ce soir
alors aulas c'est beau ça je les défends
un peu plus gros
o la série thomas le rayon il a juste
sur les seins voilà
je vais être sérieuse vraiment quand on
apprend à 30 ans qu'on a un cancer du
sein c'est un coup de massue et après
chaque réaction maladroite des personnes
qui compare la maladie à une grippe
chaque rendez vous chez le médecin
cd mini coup de massue qu on vous
rajoute le traitement il ya un côté
kinder surprise on donne les enfants
mais c'est au compte-gouttes
on m'a prescrit un traitement hormonal
pour cinq ans on m'a donné une
ordonnance comme si c'était du doliprane
j'ai les bouffées de chaleur d'une femme
de 50 ans et je pleure pour rien comme
une femme enceinte on est égaux face à
la maladie il faut nous respecter en
tant qu'homme en tant que femme avec
notre identité propre il faut respecter
notre douleur on n'est pas forcément
plus sensible parce qu'on est une femme
malade pense moi en sommes qu on soit
une femme on a mal on a peur une amie
touché aussitôt par un cancer nous
raconter une anecdote
avant son opération son chirurgien est
venu la voir dans sa chambre lui a pris
la main et lui a dit ne vous inquiétez
pas ça va bien se passer
après l'opération il est revenu la voir
lui a repris la main et lui a dit vous
avez vu ça s'est bien passé
le matin de mon opération c'est un
infirmier qui est venu me chercher dans
ma chambre et il m'a vu dire au revoir à
ma peluches et lui faire un câlin et il
m'a dit c'est amusant main fille quand
elle part à l'école elle fait la même
chose
ce matin là grâce à cet infirmier
moi aussi je suis parti à l'école on
peut faire beaucoup en mes femmes en
faisant un pas l'un vers l'autre en se
dévoilant pour mieux se comprendre
wi fi
[Musique]